un nuevo rostro para los juegos
olímpicos de tokio shake hojas y motos
la nueva presidenta del comité
organizador del evento es mujer tiene 56
años y ha sido medallista olímpica un
perfil radicalmente distinto al de su
predecesor yoshiro mori con gates night
iba a me gustaría mostrar una nueva
dirección a finales de mes
eso incluye aumentar el porcentaje de
mujeres ejecutivas al 40% mostrar
diversidad armonía y otro acento
disfruta esta es la promesa de hashimoto
después de que morí dimitiera por sus
comentarios machistas unos dichos que
muestran la desigualdad estructural
entre hombres y mujeres en japón y en el
mundo hashimoto que ya era ministra de
los juegos olímpicos es una de las pocas
figuras femeninas prominentes en la
política japonesa
y el comité olímpico actual de 35
integrantes solo tiene un 20 por ciento
de mujeres
el nombramiento de hashimoto alegró a
muchas deportistas
siento que es una buena noticia porque
estamos avanzando se van rompiendo
barreras especialmente para las mujeres
hemos tenido que luchar por tantas cosas
para ser iguales y aún así todavía no lo
somos
hashimoto ya tiene experiencia en ser
una pionera en un mundo masculino
parlamentaria desde 1995 fue la segunda
diputada en dar a luz mientras estaba en
el cargo su caso hizo que el parlamento
permitirá una baja laboral por
maternidad y como deportista compitiendo
en las modalidades de ciclismo de pista
y patinaje de velocidad fue la segunda
japonesa en ganar una medalla en los
juegos olímpicos de invierno